[Musique]
c'était à la tribune un documentaire de
Bénédicte Loubert co-écrit avec Jean
Gary qui nous fait l'honneur de
participer à cette émission bonjour
bonjour Jean Gary merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation Merci à VOUS
l'invitation de la classe 201 du lycée
Jeanne d'Albret classe de seconde
bonjour à vous les élèves merci beaucoup
d'avoir travaillé sur ce film vous
l'avez vu pendant 4 heures vous avez
travaillé dessus vous avez scruté vous
l'avez décortiqué et on va pouvoir poser
toutes vos questions sur le fond comme
sur la forme à Jean Gary mais peut-être
juste avant pour commencer l'émission
est-ce que vous pourriez me donner votre
ressenti vos impressions sur ce film
alors qui veut se lancer ça très
intéressant parce que c'est un peu une
vue que nos parents et nous on n'a pas
trop cette vue là donc c'est quelque
chose de nouveau qu'on découvre
d'accord il me semble que que la
violence des propos dans les échanges
vous a vous a un peu marqué Léna c'était
notamment pendant le discours d'Édith
Cresson la violence qui a eu c'était
assez enfin je trouve ça assez
incroyable en fait que à l'Assemblée
nationale il y ait autant de violences
et surtout qu'elle réussit à continuer
son discours jusqu'au bout même si on
l'a vu c'est voilà ça n'a pas toujours
été parfait dans tout ce qu'elle a fait
tout ça mais ouais ça m'a vraiment
choqué en fait et autant de sexisme
parce que c'est clairement parce que
c'est une femme qu'elle a reçu tout ça
c'est enfin j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement
choquant on se rend compte que même dans
le lieu même où c'est de noter ou c'est
voté bah c'est pas également non plus
mais surtout en fait les députés c'est
censé être des personnes adultes matures
et en plus ils sont censés représenter
des citoyens et parfois ils se
permettent pendant que certaines
personnes font leur discours et qu'ils
essayent de garder la tête haute un
visage neutre des commentaires déplacés
des qui n'ont pas leur place dans un
lieu de respect
Mathilde oui par exemple dans le au
cours de Christiane taubires se prenait
des réflexions comme l'a dit Léna
sexiste et même des commentaires
déplacés juste parce qu'il n'était pas
d'accord avec ce qu'elle disait et
c'était ça rejoint un peu ce qui se
passe aussi sur les réseaux sociaux ah
oui c'est à dire bah souvent on est
enfin on peut être type d'insultes parce
que notre avis n'est pas le même que
quelqu'un d'autre et ça arrive souvent
les insultes comme ça ça vous ça vous a
marqué que que des personnalités
politiques puissent autant s'insulter
Léna enfin on pourrait penser que le
fait qu'il soit filmé et donc il sache
qu'ils vont être diffusés à la télé ça
pourrait ralentir ce genre de choses
mais en réalité pas tant que ça enfin
j'ai l'impression que enfin je pense que
s'ils étaient pas filmés il y en aurait
encore plus mais enfin je sais pas je
trouve ça hyper enfin ils savent qu'ils
vont être diffusés à la télé mais
pourtant ils s'empêche pas de ça faire
des réflexions voir des insultes
économique est difficile
être vertueux puisque c'est le
vocabulaire
l'interdit pas d'être audacieux
sur un franc fort nous construisons une
France Forte la stabilité des
discrétions prend appui sur son pupitre
le corps penché elle pénètre trouvé le
rythme alors pour s'imposer elle force
sa voix jusqu'à l'excès
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi il y a autant
de haine entre les deux parties à
l'Assemblée bon c'est quelque chose qui
est vieux comme comme l'Assemblée
nationale ça a toujours été ça
l'assemblée c'est une arène où Ben
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
attendre les gens se lâchent mais vous
avez mis le doigt sur quelque chose de
très important qui est la violence faite
aux femmes il y a pas de lieu plus
machiste et plus sexiste que l'Assemblée
en tout cas jusqu'à une date assez
récente c'était le repère justement de
ce de ce machisme on attend quelque
chose quand même de beaucoup plus régulé
au moins le respect des femmes qu'on
leur dise pas qu'elles sont des
cris de d'animaux lorsqu'elles
apparaissent qu'on critique pas leur
manière de s'habiller etc et dit cresson
avait été une victime de tout ça mais il
y en a eu d'autres Dominique Voynet
Cécile Duflot enfin des tas comme ça qui
ont été victimes de d'une manière même
de concevoir la femme comme une sorte de
fin objet en quelque sorte donc tout ça
si vous voulez ça fait partie des excès
et c'est vrai que je répète jusqu'à une
date récente on avait trop tendance à
accepter tout ça et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faudrait vraiment
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus sanctionné
vous pensez vous pensez d'ailleurs que
les choses vont évoluer vous rêvez même
de ça que d'une assemblée ou tout le
monde se respecterait et parlerait très
posément oui Léna j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde parle posément ce serait
pas vraiment possible enfin parce qu'on
le voit même au débat à la télé et même
nous-mêmes quand on parle politique avec
des gens c'est quand même très rare que
ça reste calme jusqu'au bout maintenant
plus de respect ça oui j'espère surtout
envers les femmes enfin il y a eu des
évolutions maintenant jusqu'à encore
récemment il y a eu des histoires qui se
sont passées mais oui ou en tout cas que
les sanctions soient bien plus peut-être
un petit peu plus intransigeante
là-dessus parce que je pense qu'en plus
plus il y a de femmes qui se fait qui ne
se font respecter à l'Assemblée moins
les jeunes filles vont sentir légitimes
à vouloir y aller à ouais à oser dire ok
j'ai une
enfin légitimité légitimité j'ai envie
de dire ça j'ai envie de m'exposer tout
ça et je pense que ouais plus on
trouvera que les femmes aussi sont
respectés à l'Assemblée plus c'est ça il
y en aura en réalité vous qui allez être
confronté bientôt à la nouvelle épreuve
du baccalauréat avec ce grand oral
l'éloquence qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
ça évoque pour vous qu'est-ce que déjà
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de dire
là-dessus par rapport à ce que vous avez
vu dans le documentaire
c'est un peu jongler avec des mots
savoir les utiliser correctement et ça
qui fait la beauté de l'éloquence
justement
moi je me demandais en quoi l'éloquence
elle a influencé le Parlement et tout ce
qui se passe avec les discours retour
c'est je veux dire c'est la raison
d'être de du Parlement c'est de
parlementer de parler et que l'éloquence
puisse être capable de convaincre au
fond l'éloquence c'est l'art de
convaincre il y a 10 000 manières de de
d'essayer de convaincre vous pouvez
convaincre par la rigueur de vos
arguments la pertinence la profondeur de
nos arguments pouvait convaincre aussi
par une forme de séduction dans il y a
100 ans pour les grands-parents de vos
grands-parents il y avait un
parlementaire qui s'appelait qui était
député ministre qui s'appelait Aristide
Briand et on l'appelait l'endormeur ou
l'enceorceleur c'est à dire que la la
qualité de ce de son ton de sa voix
peut-être aussi les mots qu'il employait
faisait qu'il avait une capacité à
ensorceler son auditoire alors il y a
quelques députés comme ça qui ont ceux
qui ont ce talent parmi les discours que
vous avez vu au cours de
documents à
1 formule une
parce qu'il a une très belle éloquence
comparée à d'autres qui étaient moins
dans ce système là ce gilet jaune de la
visibilité routière et des tenues de
chantier et devenus en quelque sorte le
nouveau bonnet phrygien des Français qui
s'affranchissent de la résignation de
l'isolement et de ce silence meurtri des
souffrances que l'on fait par dignité et
pour ne pas céder en fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon même si on n'écoute pas ce
qu'il dit il le dit tellement d'une
manière
il pense vraiment ce qu'il dit et il est
il est à fond dans ce qu'il dit et il le
montre avec sa gestuelle avec sa voix
qui est plutôt forte et du coup on
s'intéresse à lui parce que
parce qu'il a l'air vraiment intéressé
et convaincu et convaincu est-ce que
est-ce que par exemple tu te tu te
servirais toi de ça pour pour ton grand
oral ou pour pour d'autres exercices
comme ça d'éloquence tu dirais ok là
j'ai quelque chose à prendre de ce que
je viens de voir et de ce que je viens
d'entendre c'est sûr que si on veut
vraiment se faire
comprendre il faut pas parler d'une
manière monotone il faut vraiment
insister sur des mots faire des silences
aller plus vite etc et donc c'est vrai
que c'est important de changer sa
manière de parler il y a des exemples
qui vous ont parlé oui Mathilde par
exemple dans le discours de Christiane
Tobia le fait qu'elle ose montrer les
personnes qui la dénigrer entre
guillemets je trouvais ça bah c'est fort
quand même parce que le pointe du doigt
comme ça elle l'explique elle-même que
elle joint le geste à la parole toi
c'est quelque chose qui t'a qui t'a
marqué tu te sentirais presque capable
de le faire ou peut-être pas mais je
trouvais ça courageux de sa part c'est
un exercice très très compliqué
oui en fait moi aussi c'est plus
Christiane Taubira qui m'a marqué parce
que déjà c'est une femme et en fait
dégager vraiment de la confiance et en
fait le fait qu'il y a communique avec
les
interlocuteurs mais de façon vraiment
explicite posée et en fait elle savait
ce qu'elle disait et en fait vraiment ça
m'a j'avais envie de l'écouter parce
qu'en fait c'était tellement et
tellement captivant par ses gestes que
je me suis dit
elle a un truc à dire intéressant et ça
m'a intéressé en fait
l'acte que nous allons accomplir
et beau comme une rose dont la Tour
Eiffel
assiégée à l'aube voilà enfin c'est
s'épanouir les pétales il est grand
comme un besoin de changer d'air il est
fort comme le cri aigu d'un accent dans
la nuit longue merci à vous
quelqu'un qui est capable de vous mettre
de vous faire des citations comme ça par
coeur dans un des citations notamment de
poètes ou de ou de romancier des
Antilles de la fin de d'outre-mer au
cœur de son de son discours d'employer
des mots choisis des mots qui vont qui
vont vous emporter là aussi et qui sont
effectivement de la poésie donc il y a
10 000 façons de comment dire d'avoir de
l'éloquence 10000 façons de convaincre
mais l'idée c'est ça l'idée c'est
d'essayer de pas forcément de faire
changer d'avis là ce serait tout un
débat là-dessus de faire changer d'avis
le public qui vous écoute mais en tout
cas de lui donner quelque chose qui va
véritablement non seulement les mouvoirs
mais peut-être voilà le persuader que
celui qui lui parle est dans le vrai
vous pensez que les réseaux sociaux vont
mettre fin aux formes d'éloquence
classique voire même est-ce qu'ils l'ont
déjà fait mais oui non seulement les
réseaux sociaux mais je suis bien obligé
de dire la télévision et pas seulement
la communication c'est à dire que vous
savez depuis les années on va dire
depuis une quarantaine d'années depuis
des années 80 les hommes politiques ont
pris l'habitude de s'entourer de
spécialistes de la communication
qu'ils l'ont essayé de leur expliquer
que en employant tellement telle phrase
et on se présentant de telle manière ils
allaient être plus convaincants et avoir
plus d'électeurs est-ce que tous les
discours que vous avez entendu dans ce
documentaire vous pensez que ce sont les
parlementaires eux-mêmes qui les ont
écrit
je sais pas si c'est pareil pour tous
ceux concerner mais je sais qu'il y en a
qui à qui on écrit le discours bien sûr
je pense qu'il participe aussi qu'ils
savent de quoi ça parle ou ça oui bien
sûr mais qui savent quoi dire entre
autres mais bien sûr mais bien sûr il y
a des personnes derrière pour les aider
vous êtes d'accord avec ça ouais
Mathilde je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup
pour qui les discours sont écrits mais
la plupart la manière dont me disent
leur discours c'est enfin on voit même
pas la différence donc pour moi tant que
le discours est vraiment enfin que la
personne qui le qui le prononce est
vraiment dedans et qu'elle sait de quoi
elle parle bah que ce soit elle qui l'a
écrit ou quelqu'un d'autre c'est pas
très grave clair je te voyais réagir
pour moi je pense que les discours qui
sont souvent très très longs je pense
qu'ils sont un peu aidés mais après pour
ceux qui sont plutôt courts je pense que
ils sont plutôt seuls à les écrire moi
d'un côté je trouve ça assez triste
parce que souvent quand on est convaincu
par une personne la personnalité
politique comme le président par exemple
on a été convaincus par un discours
qu'il a fait pendant la présidentielle
et je trouve ça assez triste de me dire
que ça se trouve c'est pas du tout lu
qu'il a écrit et que toutes ces phrases
punchline ont été écrites par des
communicants mais bon à la fois c'est le
jeu entre guillemets c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on peut vraiment opposer le travail
du communicant donc celui qui va
travailler finalement collaboration avec
la personnalité politique et la
politique elle-même ou le la
personnalité politique finalement ça ne
fait qu'un ça ne fait qu'un et si vous
si vous parlez y compris avec des ce
qu'on appelle des plumes ou ce qu'on
appelle aussi des ceux qui font
les discours notamment des présidents de
la République etc Christine Albanel pour
Jacques Chirac ou plus récemment
quelqu'un qui a été mon étudiant qui est
qui fait les qui participe à rédaction
des discours d'Emmanuel Macron bon
étudiant en histoire et ce sont des ce
sont d'abord des littéraires et puis ce
qu'ils font pour pour l'homme politique
va être ensuite approprié modifier
transformer mis touche par l'homme
politique lui-même et c'est pareil pour
pour les députés ou les sénateurs ils
ont des collaborateurs parlementaires
qui peuvent leur mettre leur donner des
informations des rapports des éléments
factuels des chiffres etc mais après
sont eux qui les mettent en musique qui
les mettent en bouche et puis alors vous
avez des cristianes tobira par exemple
qui elle va vous improviser totalement
son discours
quand on lui demande comment est-ce que
vous l'avez conçu il est hyper bien
structuré etc ah normalement j'avais
dans ma tête j'avais les éléments j'ai
un petit peu réfléchi avant à la manière
dont d'articuler ces éléments et hop
c'est sorti tout seul voilà c'est vous
avez comme ça des gens qui sont capables
de vous improviser des discours mais pas
des discours de 5 minutes des discours
d'une heure de deux heures parce qu'ils
ont ça en eux ils ont l'éloquence dans
la tête tout simplement Monsieur le
Premier Ministre où en est l'état où en
est l'université monsieur le Premier
ministre il est dedans il est grand
temps il faut que le gouvernement s'en
aille les idé blog de la reconquête du
marché intérieur se font les chantres de
la monnaie unique le discours politique
il est beau aussi lorsqu'il a une flamme
lorsqu'il est porté par une conviction
personnelle qui s'exprime de façon
fleurie par des termes parfois un peu
rares qui assume la singularité d'un
langage qui va au-delà des 3000 mots qui
traditionnellement sont notre viatique
langagier je trouve que ce qui est
convaincant dans un discours c'est quand
ça tient au cœur de la personne si
c'était simplement écrit par une
personne et qu'on se contentait juste de
le dire ça nous toucherait pas ça serait
pas d'impact alors que vraiment ce qui
rend par exemple le discours de
Christiane Taubira c'est que on sent
qu'elle l'a en elle on sent que ça lui
tient à cœur aussi et du coup ça nous
intéresse alors que si la personne a
fait que lire des choses que qu'elle a
même pas vu ou même pas senti bah pour
moi c'est pas convaincant non plus tu
penses même que ça se voit quand une
personnalité politique lie quelque chose
parce que malheureusement ça arrive
lis quelque chose qu'elle n'a pas
forcément vécu qu'elle n'a pas tu penses
tu penses toi est-ce que ça se ressent
oui
personnellement je pense que écrire et
dire ces deux qualités différentes par
exemple savoir mentir c'est c'est même
si c'est considéré comme un défaut
savoir bien mentir c'est une qualité
c'est un art c'est un article certains
orateurs ils sont tellement convaincus
parce qu'ils disent même si c'est pas
vrai que on y croit et
même si c'est pas eux qui l'ont créé
même s'ils n'en pensent même pas ils ne
pensent même pas la façon dont on le dit
et dont l'exprime c'est c'est ce qui
rend crédible un discours est-ce que ça
fait partie de l'égloquence pour toi
parce que c'est ça est-ce que c'est ça
aussi l'éloquence oui
on va passer une autre partie qui vous a
beaucoup intéressé en tout cas
interroger dans le documentaire c'est sa
construction sa chronologie est-ce que
pour vous ça a été une évidence de
choisir ses discours là ou est-ce que
enfin avant il y avait un plus grand
palais j'avais déjà dans la tête des
discours qui étaient à la fois si vous
voulez d'une qualité
peut-être pas littéraire mais enfin qui
avait une qualité d'éloquence suffisante
pour être intéressante à entendre et à
décortiquer et puis aussi des discours
qui est un rapport avec des enjeux très
forts de notre société c'était ça c'est
il faut trouver toujours cet équilibre
en fait si on veut les choses un peu
intéressantes
oui comment on peut rendre accessible à
tout le monde en fait surtout au nom
spécialistes et leur faire comprendre
donc le sens même des discours ou des
échanges l'idée c'était de prendre des
grandes thématiques qui étaient
justement celles de notre quotidien et
de voir à quel point ça pouvait
justement faire des enjeux et des
discours et faire et produire de
l'éloquence bon sachant que cette
éloquence il faut bien dire que dans ces
années 90 jusqu'à aujourd'hui enfin dans
les 30 dernières années elle est quand
même pas la hauteur de ce qui se faisait
auparavant pour des tas de raisons parce
que précisément la télévision les médias
les réseaux sociaux se sont emparés de
ces discours là et on choisit on
sélectionné des petits bouts comme ça
des petites phrases etc donc aujourd'hui
je le répète c'est plus la petite phrase
ou l'image choc qui prend le dessus plus
que la qualité de l'éloquence en
elle-même
et du coup est-ce que c'est enfin je
sais pas comment formuler ma question
et est-ce que du coup le fait que les
discours soit plus court avec ces
nouvelles formes d'éloquence c'est
forcément négatif ou ça permettrait de
capter plus l'attention et du coup de
bah du coup de plus convaincre plus
facilement qu'avec un long discours de 2
heures bah c'est une excellente question
c'est vrai que les il faut s'adapter à
son époque et son époque d'accélération
de du temps une époque du zapping y
compris intellectuel donc donc il faut
adapter le discours à notre époque on
peut plus faire des discours comme les
ai Jean Jaurès ou ou Gambetta à son
époque pour que les gens puissent
comment dire s'assimiler à ce qui s'est
dit à l'Assemblée nationale ben il faut
leur parler le langage d'aujourd'hui
comme le fait un russe par exemple
François Ruffin bon bah c'est quelqu'un
qui qui s'est trouvé des mots du
quotidien qui parle qui parle
aux Français incontestablement lui il
est caractéristique de cette nouvelle
génération qui s'adapte à son à son
époque et on va aller vers ça
certainement ce matin on a tapoté à la
porte de ma chambre bureau au 120 rue de
l'Université j'étais encore au lit j'ai
pas réagi la porte s'est ouverte j'ai
grogné je suis là et la porte s'est
refermée avec un haut pardon
comme j'étais réveillé je suis descendu
au petit déjeuner quand je suis remonté
les tapis de douche ne plus dans la
salle de bain la cuvette des toilettes
était récurée les serviettes changées
les poubelles vider le même miracle se
produit tous les jours ce n'est pas
l'oeuvre d'une fée mais de femme ça vous
a parlé ou vous êtes dit mais c'est qui
lui enfin ça va pas du tout la manière
dont ils s'exprime oui Léna à la fois ça
nous a parlé parce que ça rend le
discours je trouve un peu plus
accessible je dirais au grand public
mais à la fois ça restait quand même
choquant un peu je trouve enfin en tout
cas surprenant de voir ça à l'Assemblée
nationale et le fait que d'ailleurs il
est pas tant que ça de réaction autour
de lui et enfin même sa tenue
vestimentaire tout ça c'est assez
étonnant maintenant je pense que ça peut
du coup un petit peu plus parler aux
jeunes et même aux gens de notre âge
enfin un discours comme ça on va bien
plus le comprendre qu'un long discours
avec avec enfin voilà est-ce que est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec Léna vous
comprenez plutôt le oui Raphaël le fait
qu'il le fait que François Ruffin
portant pull qui disent je suis vous le
relevez dans le dans ce documentaire il
dit pas je suis il dit je suis porte un
pull quelqu'un à toqué à ma porte ce
matin bon ben on apprend plus tard que
c'était donc la femme de ménage toi
c'est un discours que tu comprends
beaucoup mieux je pense que ça nous
atteint plus aujourd'hui à notre
générations et en plus ça choque plus
plus que comme vous avez dit aujourd'hui
c'est plus le buzz et ça marche beaucoup
avec les réseaux sociaux ça va plus nous
atteindre ça va plus parler
donc nous on va plus s'y intéresser on
va ça va un peu nous choquer et donc on
va plus revenir je trouve ce discours
que d'autres et donc oui je pense que ça
ça nous attend bien plus que d'autres il
capte plus l'attention vu que c'est pas
une manière habituelle d'entendre un
discours du coup je pense que c'était
surtout fait exprès pour capter
l'attention sur un sujet qui est dont on
parle très peu finalement du coup c'est
plutôt pas mal bien sûr Tatiana
ça nous a tous surpris je pense parce
que dans l'Assemblée nationale ce sont
déjà être un endroit sérieux c'est pas
qu'un pulse c'est pas sérieux mais c'est
pas une tenue habituelle mais c'est ce
que j'allais dire on a le droit de
porter un pull et d'être très sérieux
vraiment on s'identifie déjà à lui mais
en plus le fait que il parle comme nous
bah du coup on peut vraiment c'est pas
qu'on comprend pas d'habitude mais c'est
juste que vu qu'il parle comme les
jeunes comme la majorité des gens qui le
regardent et ben du coup on s'identifie
à lui et vu qu'il parle aussi de ce
qu'on connaît dans la vie de tous les
jours ce qu'on fréquente les gens qu'on
voit qu'on croise nos habitudes et ben
du coup on arrive vraiment à savoir et à
se dire oui ça c'est c'est ce que je vis
en fait et c'est vrai que c'est pas
forcément juste et c'est vrai que ça
peut être amené à changer en fait est-ce
que ça vous viendrait à l'idée pour
votre futur grand oral par exemple
devenir en pull et de et de dire je suis
non je vous vois je vous vois sourire
non romain
pourquoi tu pourquoi tu ferais pas ça
t'inspire pas ce type de discours là tu
te dis non moi jamais moi jamais je
pourrais parler en pull et devant un
public non pourquoi
je sais pas parce qu'il y a des codes et
des normes c'est ça qu'il faut il y aura
tu voulais je te voyais réagir en fait
c'est plutôt dans le sens où ça sort de
des habitudes enfin s'ils sont s'ils
discours il était bien construit la
façon dont on présente ça peut importer
mais dans son cas je pense pas que
c'était choquant il a su s'exprimer ses
propos ils étaient enfin c'était
compréhensible et je pense que c'était
l'essentiel peu importe de la façon dont
c'est présenté Alix toujours sur le
sujet du grand oral aussi les gens qu'on
aura en face de nous ils nous
connaissent pas forcément et donc la
tenue comporte l'attitude qu'on a notre
façon de parler ça a beaucoup
d'importance dans ceux qui vont penser
nous et
simplement ce qu'ils vont nous dire
bien sûr Léna tu voulais rajouter
quelque chose c'était à peu près
que nous si au premier oral on se
présente en pull et on commence à parler
familièrement on sait qu'on va pas
capter l'attention alors que le but
c'est vraiment nous de prendre
l'attention des gens je pense que
c'était la même chose dans son cas mais
oui c'est pour ça alors qu'est-ce que
fait François Ruffin du coup mais
on pense que enfin moi personnellement
c'est qu'il sera le seul à le faire dans
l'assemblée et du coup on se dit bah
c'est pas normal mais alors que si tous
les élèves de cette classe se présentant
pull ce sera un petit peu comme si on
prenait pas les choses d'accord
sérieusement en fait qu'est-ce que c'est
l'action
parce que c'est des des questionnements
moi j'ai pas de réponse d'ailleurs mais
c'est vrai que il faut on peut est-ce
qu'il faut est-ce qu'on a un moment où
il faut commencer à casser un certain
nombre de codes parce que ces codes
isolent dissocie cette cette Assemblée
nationale de du reste des des Français
ça apparaît assez nécessaire il faut que
vous puissiez voir que nous puissions
voir à l'assemblée des gens qui nous
ressemblent y compris dans la diversité
sociale ethnique et tout ce que tout ce
que vous voudrez j'en ai comme on dit
autant de femmes que d'hommes on a
besoin de d'avoir quelque chose qui nous
ressemble et en même temps est-ce que
ce lieu qui est quand même l'endroit où
sont les représentants de la nation doit
pas avoir un caractère j'exagère un peu
entre guillemets un peu sacré un peu
sanctifié de manière à ce qu'on y parle
peut-être une autre langue et à ce que
on essaye d'élever un tout petit peu la
discussion par rapport à ce qui pourrait
être nos discussions ce qu'on appelle le
café du commerce ou à table le dimanche
donc c'est une vraie question j'ai pas
j'ai pas de réponse je pense qu'il faut
évoluer qui font casser effectivement
les codes d'ailleurs vous y êtes vous y
êtes sensible et ruffins je crois qu'il
a il a senti ça et c'est vrai que si on
veut
connaître et faire comprendre et se
rapprocher des citoyens c'est vrai qu'il
faut absolument changer changer les
codes et en même temps je le répète il
faut il faut quand même se dire que on
est dans une enceinte qui nous
représente c'est le sont les
représentants de la nation donc il faut
peut-être aussi que il y ait un certain
nombre de signes qui manifestent que
c'est un endroit un petit peu à part et
il faut trouver je pense l'équilibre
entre ça être le plus proche des gens et
en même temps montrer que il y a un
endroit qui doit être sanctuarisé ou où
on parle des choses qui sont les plus
importantes et on parle peut-être un
langage un peu différent
dès 2012 les députés accèdent à Internet
dans l'hémicycle une véritable
révolution car auparavant des
brouilleurs d'ondes étaient installés de
façon à empêcher les communications
téléphoniques avec l'extérieur
une autre façon de faire de la politique
voire de marquer des points sur ses
adversaires
[Musique]
beaucoup de Twitter probablement
beaucoup trop je pratique Twitter
pourquoi
on a laissé les députés avoir du réseau
dans l'Assemblée nationale
très bonne question très très bonne
question parce que c'était interdit
avant il faut le préciser c'est une très
bonne question
personnellement à titre personnel En
tant que citoyen moi je trouve que ce
serait bien qu'il y ait pas de réseau à
l'Assemblée nationale qui soit pas en
train de lire le journal quand certains
d'autres parlent et qui s'interromps pas
quand quand ils sont à la à la tribune
bon mais ça c'est un monde idéal et
finalement ça fait peut-être partie de
cette adaptation on en parlait ils ont
adapté leur discours ils ont adapté leur
manière d'être leur gestuelle etc leur
punchline leur petite phrase ben voilà
ils se sont adaptés aussi aux réseaux
sociaux mais je suis pas sûr que ça que
ça arrange grand chose parce que
précisément ça les conduit est
totalement tributaire de l'immédiateté
c'est-à-dire du regard que les autres
vont porter sur sur ce qu'ils disent et
au fond on attendait autre chose on
attend que il soit capable de prendre de
l'anticipation par rapport au futur ben
on parlait de Christian tobira de dire
bah tiens le mariage pour tous je sais
que ça ça provoque de l'émotion certains
de famille des gens qui sont pour des
raisons religieuses ou autres qui sont
opposés mais c'est peut-être le sens de
l'histoire et c'est la manière de
libérer beaucoup de gens ça va pas
donner du bonheur à beaucoup de gens
donc je m'engage là dessus quand Robert
Badinter en 1981 a défendu l'abolition
de la peine de mort il l'a fait face à
une majorité de Français qui qui voulait
maintenir la peine de mort mais il a
regardé plus loin est-ce que s'il avait
eu les réseaux sociaux il aurait vu oh
là là on m'insulte sur les réseaux
sociaux je vais peut-être un peu me
calmer je vais je vais mettre ma réforme
de côté vous voyez donc le l'immédiateté
comme ça elle est et l'ennemi de
l'éloquence justement les l'ennemi de ce
que devrait être de ce que sont les
représentants de la nation est-ce que
vous avez encore d'autres d'autres
questions à poser d'autres réflexions
même à nous donner sur le documentaire
en lui-même peut-être aussi sur sur
l'éloquence plus particulièrement des
conseils peut-être aussi à demander pour
pour préparer votre grand taux oui quel
message avez-vous souhaité communiquer à
quel public ah oui quel est le message
en fait du de ce documentaire s'il y
avait un message qui avait un but quel
serait-il je me permets c'était ça ta
question mais le message c'était de
montrer à quel point c'était important
qui est dans notre République un endroit
où les gens débattent de manière
ordonnée de manière organisée
confronte leurs idées et face surgir les
normes les lois qui qui nous réagissent
c'est-à-dire que le ce qui se passe dans
notre société bon on a un président de
la République qui prend des décisions on
a des ministres etc mais c'est bien
aussi qui est un endroit qui soit
installé il fasse partie de nos
institutions je le répète dans laquelle
ceux qui pensent blanc ce qui pense noir
ce qui pense gris puisse s'exprimer et
que nous ayons connaissance de de ce
qu'ils disent parce que ils nous
représente c'est ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie représentative pour moi c'est
quelque chose de très important et c'est
ce qui permet a priori d'éviter que les
débats ils se fassent dans la rue et il
se fasse à coup de poing donc confronter
des Idées c'est quelque chose de
fondamental et cultiver cet art de
l'éloquence c'est donc quelque chose de
fondamental comment j'arrive à te
convaincre comment j'arrive à te faire
passer ma conviction ce dont je suis sûr
et moi ma conviction c'est que c'est
passionnant d'étudier ces discours de
l'Assemblée nationale c'était le corps
c'est ça que je veux faire passer on va
s'arrêter là
merci beaucoup Jean Gary d'avoir répondu
à toutes ces questions merci à vous
merci merci à vous
surtout les élèves de la seconde 201 du
lycée Jeanne d'albrede avoir participé à
cette émission d'avoir posé toutes vos
questions d'avoir émis aussi vos
réflexions c'était particulièrement
intelligent et brillant et puis vous
aussi devant votre écran si vous avez
des questions des interrogations des
choses à nous dire et bien n'hésitez pas
ça se passe aussi sur internet
#2 sur Twitter et puis sur la page
Instagram de la Chaîne parlementaire à
cause de la situation sanitaire en
France aujourd'hui les premiers numéros
de la Zone d'Éducation documentaire se
dérouleront plutôt en région parisienne
mais très vite c'est promis nous
viendrons LCP viendra poser ses caméras
et apporter ces documentaires dans
toutes les écoles dans tous les
établissements de France s'est promis on
viendra vous voir donc Z revient très
vite avec une nouvelle classe et un
nouveau documentaire parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'âge pour questionner le monde et
ces images allez salut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]